what's the deal with airplane peanuts
i saw a brother take a bite out of a
vietnamese guy once dude
took a huge bite out of his [ __ ] arm
bro meat and everything bro ripped it
right out
the vietnamese guy was like threatening
with all this karate [ __ ] and everything
and his brother just scratched her
[ __ ] bit right into him
right he's thinking about it that's the
way to do it that stops karate all the
time because i don't care what type of
karate you got they got no defense for
the bite you know what i'm saying nobody
got well whatever [ __ ] goes to
bite you
oh my god hold on i gotta call the main
jab and [ __ ] it okay
let me put my komodo on it and they bite
yes dude you think you would leave your
house if you know white kids are going
to smell you i don't know
if you see an asian you're going to
smell it by the way you're going to
throw them off and smell his neck it's
like how i least i always say mel lee's
neck because i want to smell the hummus
coming out of his hair yeah you you're
going heavy on hummus though always i
guess but i i'm a little bit
i don't know what the word i should use
i have a little bit mistrust with joey
now how often are you smelling my neck
when you walk i mean i don't sniff it on
purpose i could smell the hummus leaking
out of the subway it's got to be your
neck of your earlobes
i mean you know a puerto rican moves
into your name but you want to go down
and smell the first puerto rican you
want to see why he's different
where you're from an island you don't
even know where puerto rico is when i
was a kid i met the first armenian
carnick to this day i don't know what
the [ __ ] i mean is that he's gonna do
with me i don't know what the [ __ ] i
mean is that he's from armenia
he's a great dude it's got nothing to do
with me yeah i don't what am i going to
go home and look at the globe for two
hours a microscope i need that
somebody used to kill
throw dead animal carcasses in a ditch
outside of our house right for like
seven years my mother would call every
week well come on
big animals too you grew up in africa no
[ __ ] guys like did you grow up
yeah i had a couple cats some possums in
my neighborhood the dog at the time
would walk around
as i walk into someone on it's bum day
today at 7 7-eleven oh yeah it's [ __ ]
major league but i got brothers out
there out front one brother get first of
all get him dude every black community
you got to go to your local 7-eleven
that's somebody's dad that's somebody's
uncle that's somebody every any 7-eleven
there's a brother out there right now
go get him and bring him home
brother you know i got thrown out of the
cub scouts i need this [ __ ] now you want
me how did he get thrown out of the cups
come on
[ __ ] [ __ ]
i got thrown out after the third meeting
really yeah could you see him in the
outfit bro yeah dog i always for the
[ __ ] two or three years i wanted to
be a boy scout i was always a fake boy
scout like i would buy the patches and
put them on my jean jackets you were
just like a face what is that called
like a stealing valor or something yeah
like i was a valid like when i was eight
or something or seven
i [ __ ] put a boy scout thing on
people harassed me for like years why do
you have that on oh
that's how i bought the [ __ ] jacket
you know he got the
and i thought it was the biggest
[ __ ] in the world like you had to go
to a gym for a month and time knots on a
boat what yeah i thought we're going on
the jungle yeah and building like a
titan and then no no what what jungle do
they have in new jersey i don't [ __ ]
know i got something out there but
brochure told you a [ __ ] adventure
spot
yeah then they tried to one then they
draw on the second meeting they dropped
that [ __ ] about we gotta work and pitch
tense that's where it ends right there
yeah i go to summer camp the
reservations better be made what i'm
saying yeah when i get that i want no
[ __ ] misunderstandings this better
not be ja rules festival down there with
that white dude you show up in that
[ __ ]
fire island that's fire
two accidents on the one-on-one
back to back lee late day light day two
[ __ ] right in front of me uh
once they get into the same lane it was
perfect they just went bam and then this
idiot kept going and hit him
i went right around that [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh you saw what happened i saw right and
brian beautiful and people like call the
police i ain't calling nobody it's got
nothing to do with uncle joey i got [ __ ]
to do when people say i gotta get back
in the hov language [ __ ] is always let
them fight let them gun each other down
bro so then as i'm pulling off another
[ __ ] go straight i mean this guy
shoots into the [ __ ] lane
of the people coming from like universal
city off the lancashire and he just
shoots into that lane
sideswipes the [ __ ]
i just went around then
you go by like i'm one of those eighties
beeped at him though
hey they both looked at me like what the
[ __ ] i know you did you always be bad
when you like wave i weigh both of me
it's really messed up
you're beeping and then it's like the
[ __ ] weddings
they just look at me like [ __ ]
we would go in there beautiful salad
okay go to the corner
order everything on the menu because the
acid is telling you you're hungry and
once that food comes out can we even sit
down at the table are we in the no we're
laughing the whole time when the weight
just comes we're giggling oh yeah we
don't we don't make eye contact we're
like ice teaming with women you're just
hiding behind the menu and if she does a
presentation
she goes let me tell you the specials of
the day like one of those things
we will die of heart attacks like you
pray for that not to happen you just
keep saying fish and chips and a salad
fishing chair and she's like but it's my
job to tell you we have a flounder with
artichoke juice i saw uh vince vaughn
last night at the uh comedy store too
he was just hanging out he went to him
see i guess him as steve burn his
buddies so he came out to hang out with
them
and uh
and then him and sebastian matasaka were
talking for a long time but he was super
cool i went right up to him because i
did his wild west comedy fest last year
so i went right up to and i was like
vincey
[Laughter]
and it was super cool like yeah yeah
[ __ ] at that christmas tea kettle and
if i can serve and leave a couple cups
right there boy
[Laughter]
big little fart sponge baby
welcome to africa lee
normally i like all your sayings i don't
like the fart spot sorry i'm sorry but
and i'm just joking about that i didn't
mean that
i would never say that no it's funny but
people he he's gonna take a liking to it
it's been like two podcast since he
farted on me oh dude in some countries
that's a in japan that's like a that's
like buying somebody a scarf no we're
not gonna send you photos we don't know
i'm half japanese
oh he's got the thighs of a [ __ ] kung
fu fighter son there's a kid who
torments me chin from taiwan on twitter
is great i cracked the tremendous joke
at him yesterday he goes joey i didn't
like what you said i go chin
where the [ __ ] you been driving that
[ __ ] lift uh rickshaw
and then i wrote i still got that
[ __ ]
a lift rickshaw
dude they didn't i remember the first
time they had an asian come by us right
they had a rumor they had an asian um
the first one about
maybe 17 miles away from us in hammond
louisiana right where the train used to
pick up
and uh and so we were fired up because
we never seen an asian you know we'd
seen
you know drawings of them but that was
about it
and we were like holy [ __ ] do we need to
go
and we need to see him
and so we remember we cut grass me and
two of my buddies probably for six weeks
and uh you saved up for a trip to see
the asian yeah it's like probably about
25 bucks probably to maybe get a taxi
over there
and uh and we got a taxi there and it
was just a laundromat it was like a dry
cleaners or something no asian we waited
there i remember probably four or five
hours
and uh and then we took a taxi back and
that was it man and so i think for a
long time i kind of had a um
not a feeling of abandonment but
i guess i had some sort of a feeling of
abandonment when it came to asian people
yeah mistrust like they let you down a
little bit i don't know if let me down
but just didn't
i don't know something i'd have to think
of think about it more maybe with a
therapist but something like that
you know you are you're a [ __ ] bird
it's good you stop doing drugs you do
know that right my father used to you
know he was just
he didn't have any money and he spent he
usually lived in like kind of poor
places he would
mostly buy his cars he got from a lot of
brothers local brothers you know and so
he bought a cutlass one time or delta 88
i think it was and they had speakers in
the back of it right and my dad was
you know 82 by the time he was driving
around with me you know so like
i remember
one of the speakers had that was broken
out right and he had like 12's or
something to be gotten it off this black
guy right so he didn't [ __ ] know and
he could barely hear anyway so he's just
always driving around and had this car
with these speakers in it right just
blast and
you know whatever
this is probably 92 91 92.
and one of this one of those speakers
had uh drugs in it they i guess had some
crack cocaine in there and they stopped
my dad one time found this in the
speakers and they uh impounded the car
man took the car from him and it wasn't
even his you know like they think
there's an 82 year old man doing crack
but he just bought a a car that had it
and you know just maybe somebody hit it
in a speaker or something they had um
some chinese food in there too like some
old chinese food and some uh nobody
smelled it fortune cookies no like so
old had just been dried out like this
isn't a fortune cookie you getting your
car confiscated
i still got at least not yet
that voice that you only let out in
front of your friends yeah and that your
friends like that is [ __ ] hilarious
we're having a conversation at the store
one night here like last week some guy
got found with 30 pounds of hamster
bones you know they did in my town they
just busted a man it just doesn't right
away you got to stop what you're doing
in that conversation and giggle because
9 out of 10 people wouldn't be proud of
that happened in their hometown you know
what i'm saying like they wouldn't even
mention it if somebody comes up to them
and go ah
are you from new orleans not really i'm
from texas wait a second i gotta go you
know you get to that point most [ __ ]
people would be embarrassed to say
something like that or it would take
them 10 minutes after everybody told
their story yeah to say oh by the way
there's a guy no we were just talking
it's too late
yeah we're ready to go home and you came
out with it and i'm [ __ ] me and lee
would dine in the car like what's he
talking about hamster meat what the [ __ ]
is he talking about
and that's right yeah they busted him
man
they got him what if thank god
like it's like they got him no i'm glad
they got him dude 30 pound bag of
hamster one like
i mean that's because you have to
there's not as much meat there's very
little bone in a hamster broth and ham's
got a hamp probably has
like a quart like an eighth of an ounce
in his chest plate bro you can't even
make a wish on their bones you know
there's nothing in there where do you
get all those hamsters from that's well
they breed them in our town i used to
work for this group they used to sell
tattooed hamsters and guinea pigs after
uh they tattoo them yeah they used to
brand them with concerts and raves they
would say it's tattoo just to make
people not be as sad about it
but it was a brand
of what
but like a heat and ink bruh for what
like what did it say uh 311 green day
anything like a different bands that
were coming to town toadies
swear to god bro toady's acid bath uh
who else
raves whatever bruh we used to truck
these hamps into the city and [ __ ]
just vend them bruh
we did man because there wasn't much
there wasn't much work in our town dude
you know you had to get what you could
get they had a man that bred hamsters
and uh and then they had to do the
tattoos and they [ __ ] met up and
that's a merger that's big business you
know
and they started uh
a merger they started doing it man
i got me some 300
miles in my house and [ __ ] and some
other guys like you know what man i'm a
pretty good tattoo artist
that's louisiana and that's it a merger
is fun
he was always he was one of those dudes
that always smoked weed he just wanted
really good weed yeah and uh
then a couple times he was like dog
we're going down to florida for the
weekend we don't want to [ __ ] around
gotta meet a half a pound
i would jack them 200 and a half a pound
and take a half ounce out and spray it
with water to make the weed [ __ ]
swell up and [ __ ] by the time we get to
florida he'd realize i smoked three
ounces of pot yesterday he said no you
did michael joey wet that weed like a
[ __ ]
dude i sold an ounce one time in my
neighborhood and almost lost my mind and
[ __ ]
i couldn't handle the stress man this
[ __ ] was just too stressful why i
thought everybody's gonna turn us in man
and then uh
i remember hiding in the trunk of my own
car for like a couple hours dude and
thankfully i didn't die because i didn't
know you could die in your own trunk
and um and i remember hiding in there
and thankfully my the people i was
living with came home and i heard them
park and i banged on the trunk and they
let me out i was [ __ ] up man
a lot of weird [ __ ] happened by us man
they had a dude that committed a crime
right
and then
ended up cutting off his own hands to
try and not get caught for it so he
wouldn't have his own [ __ ]
oh man
like i can see where he was thinking
with it but he just didn't take it one
step far enough yeah because they can
still catch you for it man yeah man i
got away with that i cut my hands yeah
in 10 years you kill somebody they're
gonna have everything on tape
and 10 years from now it's not going to
be okay for where was the last time you
see lee i saw him walking down comston
let's go to the videotape hit monitor
number four satellite number 483 that's
what monitors constant you're going to
see your [ __ ] kid walking down the
street and getting into what color van
and that's the way it's going to be yeah
the whole world's going to be on high
security
i think that right yeah i think so too
man i think that i worry that i wish i'd
have killed more people when i was
younger
you know what i'm saying because now
it's even harder now but then i saw you
at the store one night dude that [ __ ]
music went off i'm like what is this
going on
i'm like are they about to park a cruise
ship on the [ __ ] [ __ ] around down
there i totally got up and [ __ ]
ripped everybody up a bunch of [ __ ]
hamsters
so back to this [ __ ] acid and the
chicks [ __ ] yeah how old was she
uh high school you know this girl they
call her big shannon she was pretty you
know she was i would say reuben s for
that time period this was also
1996 maybe
and
she
she lost it man she just lost it on this
lsd you know and so she
she wanted to stay in this small bedroom
we were all [ __ ] up and we were going
in there and like pouring like warm
water on her back and [ __ ] like that
dude we were [ __ ] up but that's back
when some of the lsd would just it would
just make you do weird [ __ ] you know
like i remember we made we uh cooked a
pizza in a dryer one time on buddy's
house dude made a medium pizza medium um
pepperoni and mushroom pizza
uh
we had a we had a cycle at probably 20
15 20 times not that good
not that good overall the teeth that
took me to the bar yeah that and ended
up being a hooker and
yeah she took a little bar and asked him
for 50 bucks at the bar how much do you
want i don't know we didn't even just go
the freak's coming yeah she said she she
said she'd make me like feel like the
like the sexiest man alive she wanted to
go to a hotel and watch a movie it was a
weird i had just met you
we were sitting outside of the ha ha he
left she'll hide your chin and her [ __ ]
i bet one of them gals you know
you think she might have she was nothing
but she had a bandage on her head though
so it wasn't good oh she's in it to win
it usually she got yeah she got hit in
the head she's committed dude she has a
bandage on her head and she's still
trying to [ __ ] dude she's
you know she's probably from detroit or
from like up in that area like if you
[ __ ] to me i just wait and rob your
house
like i just robbed your [ __ ] house
that's it like you're getting your house
robbed that's it that's always the plan
and i'm taking the most important thing
to you in that [ __ ] house
if you i would steal eight ball cash
jewelry but if i knew they loved their
sneakers i'm taking the sneakers too so
when you see them they're like man
somebody busted into my house and took
my sneakers they took my mother's
jewelry
you just steal their spoons everything
anything that i knew would get them i'm
a professional torturer and when i got
to boulder in 87 i got the balls and
got the boulder in
december colorado six yeah i was running
from cops and drug dealers there were
like sixty thousand in cash so you went
to boulder i was an aspen i was an aspen
[ __ ] causing damage
in the 86 please please you have no idea
doug i was international you understand
so i'm up in aspen i [ __ ] up
with the girl i'm with from boulder we
had all i had already a warren in
boulder
and i'm like let's take a chance let's
move back to boulder i get pulled over
no war and you were on your way tip top
magoo
[Music]
[Music]
you